[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui mais ne pas paraître cette semaine
j'ai pas pu éviter le sujet de
conversation de l'or qui est le
déboulonnement de la sculpture de john
un mec dans nombre on se rappelle que la
sculpture qui trône au centre ville ont
été débouclées déboulonner excusez-moi
in extremis par des militants anti
brutalité policière anti colonialiste
parce que ils trouvaient ça
insupportable d'avoir une figure
emblématique du canada qui trompe de
même dans toute sa gloire alors qu'ils
représentent aussi une problématique
énorme du racisme systémique au canada
il a une historique très saine a accepté
comme étant celle d'anvers où deux
représentants de l'historique canadienne
et qu'elle commun qu'il est quand même
été à la base un des créateurs de la loi
sur les indiens du système des
pensionnats donc est-ce que l'on peut
accepter que puisque c'est un personnage
est problématique que l'on arrache sa
sculpture le sud conversation est
tellement touchant et aussi comment
chose de sensible que j'ai décidé de
venir sur le mont royal pour déboulonner
la croix donc je fais des farces je ne
ferai pas ça mais c'est pour représenter
quand même que si on veut voir autour de
nous les symboles de colonisation de
colonialisme d'oppression il en existe
énormément
alors là on peut penser à la croix sur
le mont royal qui représente quand même
la colonisation et
la conversion souvent très fort c'est
des communautés autochtones
on peut penser aussi juste au
centre-ville de montréal james guillaume
qui a son nom un peu partout sur tous
les bâtiments de l'université médias qui
dernièrement ont été découverts comme
étant propriétaire de plusieurs esclaves
dont certains qui étaient des enfants de
moins de 10 ans autochtone et afro
descendants donc on peut nommer d'autres
figures champlain quartier d'où sont une
historique compliqué difficile avec
beaucoup de groupes qui subissent encore
à ce jour la discrimination le
colonialisme ont des lois de pression
qui malheureusement sont au détriment de
leur histoire de leur vécu
cependant des fois j'ai trouvé que dans
les grands médias
le sujet de conversation dévie
énormément par rapport à raconter
l'histoire expliquer pourquoi justement
des gestes comme celui qui a été posée
contre la structure de mecs dans nos ont
été faits pour plutôt entrer dans une
discussion de peut-on faire ça peut-on
pas faire ça et aussi il le poids de la
justification est tombé sur beaucoup les
communautés autochtones
est ce que vous êtes d'accord est ce que
vous appuyez ce geste est ce que vous
vous trouvez que c'est correct ou pas
correct et de demander aux chefs aux
communautés autochtones s'il trouve que
ce geste ait validé ou non ça c'est
énormément problématique puisque
beaucoup des chefs qui ont été contactés
ne sont pas des chefs de qui vivent ou
travaillent au sein de la ville de
montréal
alors vous comprendrez que hausse aucune
action se passe à quelque part et qu'on
va chercher le pignon d'un chef à
l'extérieur de la ville
c'est qu'on veut associer ce sujet à une
identité racialisée une entité
culturellement points au dessus pour
pouvoir rassembler l'idée dans un seul
groupe
alors que moi j'aurais aimé entendre
beaucoup l'opinion des gens qui ont posé
cette action là qu'on le fasse en
solidarité ou non avec les communautés
autochtones faut pas oublier que
certains groupes autochtones sont pour
ce genre d'action extrêmement symbolique
pour dire que nous arrêtons la
colonisation le colonialisme au canada
et d'autres communautés
il faut pas oublier en sondant à régler
des problématiques liées aux
colonialistes donc
régler les problématiques de pauvreté de
perdre deux langues deux paires de
culture liée à l'est au pensionnat font
que peut-être souvent ils ne connaîtront
peut-être pas l'histoire de la fameuse
sculpture alors leur demander l'opinion
c'est pas nécessairement pour pouvoir
dire que la conversation va avancer
cependant beaucoup de sujets de
conversations ont été portés de l'avant
que j'ai beaucoup apprécié comme celui
de plutôt que d'arracher la sculpture
nécessairement que le geste devient le
symbole en tant que tel expliquer
l'histoire du colonialisme et s'est
expliqué l'histoire de mes canons
et peut-être maintenant créer des
oeuvres qui redonne justement une place
dans l'histoire aux personnes qui ont
été victimes de colonisation et là on le
voit souvent injustement des lieux comme
certains pensionnaires qui deviennent
des lieux historiques où on peut
raconter l'histoire des communautés
autochtones la même manière qu'on va
avoir des endroits qui vont rappeler la
shoah qui vont rappeler justement
l'histoire de l'exclavage aux états unis
et bien certains lieux nous ont
nécessairement besoin d'être des
colonisés mais pas nécessairement en
enlevant uniquement le symbole mais on
leur contextualisant en redonnant la
voix est aussi la présence à ces
personnes qui ont vécu ces systèmes de
pression alors peut-être que le plus tôt
que le déboulonner uniquement la statue
de monsieur meyer on pourrait laisser
une sculpture avec à en l'honneur des
personnes qui ont fait partie de ces
biens de ses possessions et que ses
possessions là sont eux à la base
l'économie que créer l'université mais
j'ai donc recommencé à raconter
l'histoire du point de vue des personnes
qui ont été opprimés serait extrêmement
important
parler des personnes qui ont été
kidnappés par jean cartier renommer le
pont champlain avec le nom de quelqu'un
qui vient de l'histoire des communautés
autochtones à montréal ou en montérégie
il ya beaucoup de possibilités de
recontextualiser l'histoire de la peau
de la réécrire ni de l'effacer mais
vraiment de lui donner sa place et
d'honorer les gens qui malheureusement
ont souffert au cours des derniers
siècles
alors je remercie beaucoup pour votre
écoute n'hésitez pas allez vous informer
n'était pas à
votre histoire et à écouter justement la
parole de ces personnes qui veulent se
faire entendre sur la décolonisation
je souhaite une belle semaine il n'était
pas non plus à partager cette vidéo